In this problem, an adult male is
exposed to arsenic through drinking
water. If the maximum contaminant level
in drinking water is 0.01 mg per liter
and an uncertainty factor of 100 is
applied, what is the approximate daily
intake level in mg per kilogram day that
would be considered safe and not
expected to result in adverse health
effects?
So, if you don't know where to start
with this problem, we can begin by
trying to pull some key words out of the
problem statement.
Searching for the term uncertainty
factor will bring you right to the
sections you need in either the civil or
the environmental manuals. I mention
this because this type of question may
be fair game on either the water
resources or strictly environmental
exam.
We can also see that our final answer
needs to be in the units of mg over
kilogram day.
Finally, we can look at the words
approximate daily intake level which has
a similar wording to the definition of
the term reference dose in the same
section of the manual.
So let's start by writing down our
equations that contain the term
reference dose.
There are a few to choose from here. I
started with the one that also contains
the term for drinking water equivalent
level since that is the source of our
contaminant in this problem statement.
So our first equation is going to be
dwel which is the drinking water
equivalent level is equal to the
reference dose RFD
time weight over Q which is our amount
of water consumed. More on that later.
I also see that the phrase not expected
to result in adverse health effects is
included here.
This would equate most closely to the
term noel or no observable adverse
effect levels.
We can see that the manual provides us
with an equation for noel that contains
both terms for reference dose and for
uncertainty factor which is included in
our problem statement.
[Music]
The equations will look slightly
different in the civil manual and I will
discuss that briefly at the end of the
problem.
So the second equation is going to be
the reference dose equals no over
a total modifying factor MF
times an uncertainty factor UF.
Now that we have both of these
equations, we can simplify by
substituting all of the terms from our
second equation into our first equation.
If you prefer, you can also solve them
separately. So we're going to rewrite
this as the dwel
equals the null
over the modifying factor times the
uncertainty factor
times the body weight
over the amount of water ingested.
[Music]
And now that we have all of our terms
defined, we can begin replacing
variables with values from the problem
statement and the reference manual.
So our DWL is going to be equal to the
maximum contaminant level in the
drinking water.
This is going to be 0.01 mg per liter.
We are solving for the noel.
Our modifying factor MF isn't given. So
we will assume that it's one
and our uncertainty factor is given as
100.
This leaves us with terms W and Q.
In the environmental reference manual,
these can be found a few pages below the
equations in a section called intake
rates.
An adult male is assumed to weigh 78 kg
and is assumed to drink 2.3 L of water
per day.
Note that in the civil test, these
values would likely need to be provided
since this intake rates table is not
available.
Plugging in these values into our two
equations, we can see that the terms
begin to cross out
and leave us with the units that we
desire.
[Music]
Solving for our final unknown,
we can see that the noel is equal to
0.0294 0294
mg per kilogram day, which is our fourth
answer on the left.
So, this problem has a lot of different
hints to help you find the right section
of the manual to help you. If you can
figure out which two equations to use
based on the wording of the problem,
solving it will be easy. The actual exam
may even be more explicit than I was in
making this problem. So, even if you
have some trouble with the problem
statement, practicing solving it here
once will still hopefully help you to
gain some familiarity with this section
of the reference manual.
And that's all it takes to solve this
problem.